and this first one I believe was
actually a photo taken by Brendan it's a
friend of your guys's mr. Joe Rogan at
the Hollywood improv so yeah he showed
up in this thing but to Joe's credit
he's coming from a 90's party it's
coming from a 90's party theme party
we're in New Jersey I don't know but he
looks like a member of khabib training
camp oh yeah that's a khabees camp he
looks like pitbulls like he's like he's
uh it looks like a war it looks like one
of um
BJ Armstrong's warm-up jerseys looks
like pit bulls he looks like you
straight off the set of Royal Tenenbaums
yeah Ben Stiller steroid brother that's
bro joke and right there uh yeah it
looks like I'll sell you the best
winstrol at gold yeah I guess syringes
in his back he look like you literally
he'll pop three humming you at the mote
and just see which one kind of activates
your skin the best yeah I definitely see
looks like the guy you go to if you want
to pass the drug test
we dog on the street they call mr. Pico
definitely seems like he seems like that
school bus driver
that's just driving everybody straight
to the gym even if they want to go home
yeah your after-school activities are
the gym that's it yeah it looks like
whenever you see him you ask how many
pushups you can do dude in the fanny
pack he has extra triceps in the fanny
pack yeah it's definitely a rare uh it's
definitely a rare uniform for him I've
never seen him that uniform yeah I mean
it's just not his style arias though
they had the match and red shoes I
couldn't stop laughing different party
was it did he reference it during a set
yeah yeah yeah he told everyone what's
going on well party was it then he
crushed the crowd what then he went to a
mentos 90s 490 steam party for with it
with his wife she dressed up in the 90s
dude r.i.p Billy conforto I went to a
crawfish boil one time with Billy
conforto and he's from the West Bank in
New Orleans which is based like a little
bit of New Jersey right on the edge in
New Orleans on the swamp and they had a
whole family of four and they were all
wearing these at the party tannenbaum
style yeah and they were it was not like
a joke it was like oh we all got
yeah that's kind of we got this status
net yeah they had two kids and the wife
is always weird when the family's all
dressed up is the same yeah it's always
a weird vibe yeah right it's yeah it's
kind of it has that a Stockholm Syndrome
me kind of thing it just gives me bad
vibes yeah we're a mean what if that's
the ultimate sign of teamwork man you
might be right maybe I'm just not a good
team player
no I'm yeah I mean I'm just trying to
think of it a different way like well
you know my promise I'd twins growing up
the names were Raymond Adam and they
were twins and that's why I hate twins
this day because we didn't get along
twin brothers no they're my cousins our
arch-nemesis oh well they're twin sweet
fight on the spot yes whatever we saw we
do scrap my brother go you better get
ready my girl right [ __ ] so their
name was Raymond Adam so we'd fight to
the death basically oh yeah they would
always dress the same always and then
we'd be [ __ ] them up like bear and I
get grass stains on my shirt I shut the
[ __ ] up yeah
Raymond and add I don't not see him
either Raymond Adam but I see on streets
today yeah yeah Raymond and Adam you
mother that's the same dress the same
who are you I don't look swaggy though I
like to is hilarious
I mean look it's still Joe Rogan under
the outfit so you know you got to say
you got a dope and with the fanny pack
and why'd you post them up and rip my
drift in well because it's dope I see a
minute I'm saying like sometimes my trip
you don't have to the rib doesn't have
to be too bad ya know it's like the
toughest member khabib team he does and
why was it hallo it's not even Halloween
no what were they dressed enough I don't
know 90s party I thought there well you
know sometimes they do not this theme
yeah yeah that's true
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching